48 ساعه من الخوف والترقب عاشتها اسرائيل
في انتظار تفاصيل ما وصف بحدث امني خطير
على الجبهه الشماليه كانت البدايه من
تفجير عبوه الناسفه في حيفا صباح الاثنين
الماضي اسفر عن اصابه اسرائيليين بجروح
خطيره لتبدا تحقيقات بشان من وضع العبوه
عند مفترق مجد جنوب حيفا اظهرت التحقيقات
ان العبوات التي انفجرت عند المفترق ليست
كتلك التي يستخدمها الفلسطينيون ما اشرع
الباب لاحتمال شبه مؤكد ان عمليه مفترق
مجد نفلت باياد من خارج اسرائيل وبعد تكتم
وتعتيم اعلامي طويل رفعت الرقابه العسكريه
الحظر عن تفاصيل الحدث الامني وفقا لروايه
الجيش الاسرائيلي فان منافذ عمليه مجدو
تسلل من نقطه غير معلومه عابره للحدود من
لبنان الى شمال اسرائيل استقل المنفذ
سياره وقطع سبعين كيلو مترا حتى وصل
الجنوب حيفا حيث زرع العبوه الناسفه عند
مفترق مجدو ثم استقل سياره عائدا الى
الحدود الاسرائيليه مع لبنان يقول الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان عمليات تفتيش واسعه قادت
الى الوصول للسياره التي استقلها المنفذ
طوقت قوات الجيش الاسرائيلي المنفذه في
بلده يعاره حيث كان يحمل حزام الناسفا
معدا للتفجير ما استدعى اطلاق النار عليه
وقتله ورغم الحظر الخانق الذي فرضته
المؤسسه الامنيه الاسرائيليه خلال اليومين
الماضيين على الحادثه تسرب هذا المقطع
لعمليه القبض على السائق الذي اقل منفذ
عمليه مجدو المؤكد ان هذا الحدث لم ينتهي
بقتل المنفذ بل انه صفعه لاجهزه الامن
والمخابرات داخل اسرائيل
فمنفذ هجوم مجد ظل طليقا يتجول فوق
الاراضي الاسرائيليه ليومين اما السؤال
الاهم فهو كيف عبر الحدود الى داخل
اسرائيل روايات كثيره واحتمال عده يمكن ان
تقال الاعلام الاسرائيلي تحدث مثلا عن
تسلل منفذ هجوم مجدو عبر نفق من جنوب
لبنان الى شمال اسرائيل وان صدقت هذه
الروايه فهي مسار حرج للجيش الاسرائيلي
الذي اعلن نهايه 2018 تدمير سته انفاق
هجوميه لحزب الله تخترق الحدود اللبنانيه
الاسرائيليه يقول الجيش الاسرائيلي انه
يحقق في مسؤوليه حزب الله عن هذه العمليه
والاستنفار الامني الذي اربك اجهزه الامن
والمخابرات في اسرائيل لن ينتهي بمعرفه ما
حدث بل سيبقى الى حين الرد على من يقف
وراء الاختراق الامني الخطير وفق وصف
الجيش الاسرائيلي